[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a des postes
je connais c'est quoi vous connaissez le
principe des bahamas du post on va
récompenser les meilleures séquences de
la semaine et on commence avec avec ces
nominations regarde
[Musique]
matthieu delormeau
la balayette alors maintenant quand on
rentre sur même la balayette la cause du
retard de sa coupe de cheveux brillants
peas et surtout colis toujours tu l'as
dans le tunnel
benjamin castaldi ans claude alexis
pour matthieu delormeau a enfin joué
avec son gaston be
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
rapidement je suis là fait plus rire là
le dernier a non pas le dernier soldat a
non pas le dernier pas du tout on a là
rien de le voir non à se débrouiller du
coup ballaman la balayette le premier
comme un nom comme étant plus d'attendre
et compris le principe que c'est ça ou
non le choix
qu'est ce qu'il n'avait plus fait
rigoler dans ces trois séquences rien
[Rires]
alors bernard dallas cowboys et oui je
suis payé univers alors à balayer tout
ça balayait que leurs mots leurs mots
jeanne moi c'était les
le dernier allait tonneau avec avec
qu'est ce qu'un big bang bang aime
beaucoup les manèges qui secoue match
est très content d'être là dedans voilà
m'a fait rire mais dans la voiture garée
la tête de mathieu d'accord oui je sais
vous en claude alexis en saison la belle
la briette des tablettes en dans l'ain
qu il avait les yeux la merci des
gorilles les bodin's mais j'aurais aimé
que ça dure plus longtemps avec match je
crois qu'il allait vomir à vous auriez
vous aimé pas mathieu gibaud couderc on
embrasse que bastos et il s'est planté
faire un gros bisou dit pas beaucoup
mieux je l'étais avec vous après midi la
fête fier c'est que son beau corps
d'esthète à prix d'athlète
on est tous rappella comme commune vi
carottes qu'on a passées à la blague
et du coup il a le popotin ici la halle
maman c'est torah pailhas et c'est
dégueulasse je pense
ludivine au nom la séquence le remake de
taxi ou titoff m'avoir avec sa perruque
comme ça du coup comme ils ont tous dit
quelque chose je ne sais peut piquer
gagner on va dire oh non on va dire que
ces ondées d'accès on n'a que deux c'est
naturel oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
neuf aliens alors d'accord quant à la
balayette la course de tacots de sa
coupe de cheveux blonds fils et surtout
qu'on dit toujours tu n'as donc une âme
à la radio en ville de balayette je te
remets très peur de dénoncer cette
magnifique récompense allait on passe au
baba suivant de l'économie tu là ça va
deux minutes
je ne fais beaucoup gêné à la recherche
alors alors bois rouge ehpad et vous
alors là franchement pas du tout on
passe la meilleure vannes la meilleure
vannes les nominés sont
[Musique]
jean luc lemoine et cyril hanouna
lynette scavo dans desperate housewives
felicity huffman elle marche au rite la
sauver et elle frôlait le prend la main
ont fait un petit tour
ça a duré quelques secondes pour la
première fois je n'ai pas dormi chez le
maire aujourd'hui débat refusé mois mais
dans toute la presse dans la bouche de
beinheim oui pardon mais dans toute la
presse vous avez changé
non mais dans matthieu delormeau mai
2008 censée gênant quoi qu'est ce qu'il
me prend la main elle m'a dit j'ai froid
je trempe roman dans tes bras mais il
faut jamais dit ce tournoi je vais pas
pouvoir ken tout l'été
alors moi vous avez vu ma tête ça m'a
fait rire voilà n'a pas jamais normal
jamais aux amis aux deux au dessous de
la ceinture au dessus l'esprit c'est
lève toi c'est cher alors qu'est-ce
qu'il va plus mathieu mathieu lord
toujours rien merci
la première première cirque maxime accès
pas grand chose à remplacer mais rien
ici on est là pour dire la vérité ça il
faut s'exprimer vous aimez rien il m'a
dit que je n'aimais rire voilà maxime la
spontanéité de son du clown pourquoi
vous devez tour des phrases pour des
reprises qui on donne de réponses pour
la première par l'udc jean luc jean luc
jean luc jean luc temps luke mais selon
lui par le quai dans le jeu michel mr ça
va donc cesser dans le guen qui remporte
évidemment ce matin celle là c'est là
j'adore cette catégorie a on voit bien
ce qu'on peut la revoir
bien sûr on va la revoir évidemment
évidemment on va la revoir
wells zhenhua oil et cyril hanouna j'ai
repéré
lynette scavo dans desperate housewives
felicity huffman elle marche sourit-elle
sauver et elle ne frôle elle me prend la
main ont fait un petit tour
ça a duré quelques secondes pour la
première fois je n'étais pas
[Rires]
avec ce énième message de matthieu
delormeau toujours sympathique la
carotte m'emmerde embrasse tous les
copains merci pour les messages